okay cool okay also don't forget to pick
your character
pick your character alana okay hang on i
need to delete it
do that pump slump with the oh spray
bottle
ah i think i'm gonna go to the regular
just the lady just the regular she's
cool cute she's a cool gal i like a nice
hat
i picked this one because it looks like
me i agree my grub hub literally just
survived
right now it has been delivered
yes a lot of okay oh so
here you go uh x is whip
crowd yep we can't whip each other
but you can throw objects in here we can
one hundred percent
there is oh yeah also
watch out for those those have punching
things in them okay if you hold down
and hit x on an item you'll pick it up
okay and then don't press it but b is a
bomb
you'll throw it and if you want to drop
a bomb you hold down and you press b
and you'll drop a bomb how do you oh
cool and then why
is a rope it shoots a rope up oh the
environments are actually destructible
but yes they have a certain amount how
do i take this bomb out of my hands i'm
nervous
awesome uh hold down and press x oh you
just press x and you'll throw it forward
yeah you use it as an enemy
okay or as a projectile sorry but i want
it in my inventory
so pick it up there is no inventory oh
yeah you just you hold things and you
put them down and pick them up
oh i see okay i got the ham so you guys
are all
oh yeah hamster oh how to not stick to
thing to go down
oh who is this man look out for him he's
bad oh god
this is a lot something got thrown in
the hamster
if we get the handstand at the end it'll
heal us
okay okay uh i'm having trouble with the
movement because i just keep sticking to
things i don't expect to oh yeah you
stick the corners like the corners of
huh okay i see yeah you like grab onto
them naturally
all right all right there's the end we
made it a lot of this is farther than
most of us made it our first time all
right
it'll be a little health factor and if
you die you turn into a ghost and then
we'll find your coffin in the next room
yeah cool cool when you're a ghost you
can freeze things by spitting on them
oh watch out those are traps a lot see
those okay oh yeah
so the traps only have one shot and no
what happened to this turtle oh this
turkey duck
oh buddy he's just taking a nap oh [ __ ]
alana watch this are you watching me or
uh yeah uh
is your cat well because your cameras
get stuck to one oh hang on no i'm
not no
i'm the blue guy so watch this see this
is a dead turkey throw a bomb at him
happy thanksgiving
amazing i got us a hamster nice
i'm gonna buy the compass took a long as
[ __ ] yeah i don't know that i had
anything can you see my ghost
i can you're uh-huh
oh did i hurt you oh i'm sorry i thought
that maybe it would help
oh heck if you it doesn't hurt us it
just knocks this over
okay hold it down and when you start
glowing and you spit on something you'll
freeze it
ah neat can i help you oops i dropped
the hamster
all right we made it yeah it's very
helpful when you freeze enemies
sometimes
cool okay we gotta find your cough and
get you back look at that
puckered belly button on this man i
gotta i'm gonna freeze him i'm gonna
freeze him i'm gonna i'm gonna help
it's like a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] let's get alana back thank you i
don't know
very long oh oh oh oh oh oh
where are we going so jacob we're going
this way oh
i've been rested hold on i think you
guys i think you guys maybe need some
help here you're right
oh take me forth john it's my first
threesome
not my first
[Laughter]
wait wait what even humped me it was the
trap oh i thought it was above it
oh heck okay what the
[ __ ] man hey lana yeah hey
check out this pot that's a cool pot
here throw it i just break it uh
oh what did you do i don't know what
happened
[Laughter]
i was laughing
incredible glass on my teeth that is 100
percent
not supposed to happen oh my gosh did we
you broke it
we broke it a little bit that's
hilarious
uh hello everyone welcome to
um i you said that all of my streams
so apparently if i try to use my money
change are we doing that uh in discord
it all tabs out so
on the commands out of the game so um
try to do that
yeah literally literally you're back
oh where are we going okay look out this
boss boy
oh damn if only you were still a ghost
you could have frozen him he is big and
cute look at him all right look at his
stupid i'm gonna trick him into
i'm gonna trick him into chasing me okay
nope
[ __ ] you oh no he's just i don't i'm
really jumping
oh we went jumping in
here i'll freeze him freeze check him
get him nice
oh so freezing them like that makes them
yeah basically one shot you can smash
them
nice it makes it murderable oh my god
i'm
i i this is i know it's a roguelike in
that you know you're supposed to
repeatedly do it and learn
but wow but but wow there's a lot going
on
i have never learned i know my whole
life if i learned it i'm proud of it
that's why i'm a bigot
oh there's a dude with a shotgun over
here yeah that's all that's the only
[ __ ] with him oh actually exactly i was
referring to brandon
i'm more helpful to you like this so
lana the way the game works
is that there are four worlds oh nice um
each with four ram or like stages okay
um wait so that was like that was like a
boss fight stage then yeah
yeah yeah we basically we're now in
aries oh i first are wrong questions i'm
sorry about that
that's okay that's my bad chill how to
change direct it's that neverland
oh no oh pressure's gone again you found
the
oh i almost got smashed by a friggin go
in morning start
no oh i'm sorry i didn't do it i didn't
i'm so sorry there's so many things that
i don't understand
going on right now
can i go talk to this person or are they
gonna [ __ ] my [ __ ] up yeah you can talk
to him
that person has a special challenge
where you go into their room
and you mine uh they let you mine as
much as you can
i don't think i try to get the dog at
[ __ ] kill me
i'll try to get the dog nice
i'm really scared couple of dog that i'm
gonna do
that room that room that room is free
you just mine as
far as you can and you get coins and
stuff okay
oh oh i have a double jump dog
oh yeah oh oh i have zero dog
you cook how do i enter a door
rb yeah so you say that but
maybe they're referring to this door is
this a door
can i switch yes hey you're trapped with
me oh my god what
is this i feel protected you found
something
oh that so that like prevents the ghost
from coming for a while
okay hold on because alana basically if
you break we broke that uh
jar and it uh
it caused the ghost to come but also if
you take too much time
the ghost will appear well i have this
pickaxe now so
nice cool you can mine through walls
cool
yeah pickaxes should we get this chest
up here this is like a thing that
we would want oh i don't know how to get
there
i'm really not even getting the hang of
how this i put this down oh there's a
down an axe there you go yeah this is
who i said
what's going on watch this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
no no i threw the thing i feel like we
should go around
that dude looks mean can we not get to
that chest
it's kind of high if you have a rope you
can get to it
no i don't know the exits right below us
what is these men who have dollar signs
over their heads oh that's a shop
yeah i died i'm gonna go grab my food
okay
get your chicken i see the exit alone i
think i'm just gonna go for it
okay oh okay well
oh god oh god
well we oh [ __ ] that what what we're
back at the beginning
oh my god there's so much happening this
game oh [ __ ] what the heck
i'm sorry i just don't understand any of
the rules
i just wanted to throw the rock at the
spider but the rock triggered the arrow
trap and the arrow trap hit us in the
face
jesus oh [ __ ] oh that's gonna be a yeah
it's gonna be [ __ ] myself oh hamster i'm
sorry
sure that um thing is working
kitty
yeah okay i'm gonna
i'm back we
no comprehension of really what's
happening to me so okay hamster stay
right here
i gotta whip the spider so alana this
game is like
very systems oriented so everything
interacts with each other
okay so a lot of times like you know
what can happen is
one of these sloth punchy things can hit
a rock and it launches the rock oh there
you go
and it launches the rock and the rock
flies
and kills you dorylan i'll carry your
body i heard just so many rules you know
yeah you slowly learn it over time like
yeah
i've only ever gotten to the second area
or or actually i guess last time
we got to the third area yeah we got
that
i want to freeze this punk yeah i'll
kill that punk
nice yeah john's a ghost jar right there
you want to take it the door's right
below it
okay get that diamond jacob you're so
cute look at you don't play
tell me to do push-ups do a push-up one
two hey why'd you stop you only told me
to do one push-up
oh yeah i should have said drop and give
me a number i was counting you up man
come on
okay look at how sad i look about it oh
i got horchata
drop and give me five one two three
four five all right now uh do
get this baseball glove i don't know
what this but it looks cute
it lost five thousand dollars mickey's a
[ __ ] capitalist
get it yeah what does it do maybe i can
throw stuff farther let's see
although that's not how many maybe you
could catch up oh throw in a straight
line you throw in a straight line that's
awesome awesome
that's awesome is it it is awesome
okay everything in this game is awesome
oh the spider oh everything is cool and
you're part of the team
how why won't i flip oh you have to
aim first and spit
okay well that's what we snickering
about nothing no nothing
goes oh the hamster that's a frozen ham
stuff
oh what up girl and i'm gonna die again
so what is that
oh that's that's chicken that's a bee
it's jacob oh
it was moving very quickly i got very
stressed good job look out
oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh got
we break the pot or we take if you break
the pot or he takes you longer
oh gosh okay what how to get pug
oh i hit him i'm still alive i'm sorry
but i was going to take you with me oh
my god
hello i'll take my stuff
[Music]
you have a friend you have to take that
pug all the way to the end okay
are you on a talk i am on a turkey oh my
god what do you want what
what about it just unexpected
i think that's what i look like whenever
i listen to the duma tunnel soundtrack
oh what happened i may have hit a trap
oh heck all right alana it's all you now
oh no
i need to go grab my uh gochujang mayo
okay yeah go a lotta go
where am i going this way maybe
uh yeah go down oh god keep going
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh trap yeah oh the hands my
the bug saved you it's a corpse you
could leave it behind
look out what the hell i didn't think
you'd be able to do that
i'll spin it [ __ ] i missed look out for
his belly button is puckered and swollen
got oh my god oh my god
okay okay okay okay should i break them
down oh
second too late i hate myself i pressed
a instead of x
god damn it damn it damn it okay a is a
very
nice button this video game makes me
feel like i've never played a video game
before in my life yeah
yeah yeah that's great i feel like this
is the first
game anyone's ever shown me and i'm like
no cool
holy [ __ ] look how that thing's gonna
come alive jacob
oh you're right well now i just gotta
hang out
with me am i supposed to hang out with
this guy now you can jump on his head
nice yeah so the way a lot of enemies
work is either their one shot
or you jump on their head and they get
stars and then you can't damage them
again
okay so see this guy got little birds
around his head
yeah and he won't get damaged until
check it out
oh sorry dad so these guys
these lizards i think oh i can get
faster that didn't occur to me three
hits
belly button guys belly button guys
three hits
[ __ ] really at least in the first game
they were
look at us go wow look i made it i did
it let's go
oh oh my god this is going great hey
thank you for coming
man we've already raised like 100 in
this just this stream thank you everyone
appreciate you all so sorry i'm paying
so much attention to your videos
it's yeah there's a lot happening so
what this is fully done
though yeah that's dark okay bring your
churches
there's a whole gaggle of her how do i
sit on turkey
he's gotta jump on it ride it for a
little bit
oh there's a spider
oh god this is a different turkey than
what i was writing
how swollen this turkey's like
turkey i lost my turkey oh no it's all
right sorry
all right okay it's okay i don't need
tucky
hey you stupid rap rap rat maybe
wow i got a key beaver
bat [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i've got a key where's the cave
oh god everybody's dead i'm glad you
asked chat listen there may have been
hidden favorites
is i can't say tomato one or the other
ones
also like anything that's like chicken
pesto kind of situation
uh yes this is it on my forehead pays
for it look at it look how perfectly in
this oh we can gamble
down real quick be very careful
you can kill yourself with those dice oh
i've done it
[Laughter]
you mean like that
oh my god i was like there's no way it
could happen
oh god oh god oh god oh god
that thing has hit me so many times and
every time i'm like cool a totem i
wonder if it isn't off
no no those like dart traps still kill
me
constantly what do the dot traps look
like are those the the same
yes these aztec and dragons gotcha so
how do you avoid them no not me
you have to trigger them so here look oh
nice and then they're good to go but
otherwise i'll get you every time
what happened i accidentally threw
oh my gosh oh [ __ ] yeah got it
we got a friend and he wants to get the
ghost
ghost vase okay if you drop it
oh no the ghost is gonna come but we'll
take it to the end and then break it and
then how do i make sure i don't drop it
uh jacob you can deliver the hamster
do your best it's just i don't know what
that means
i mean we're here at the end yeah let's
throw it you want me to throw it
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh god
i'm so sorry i just thought that b was
thrown but as it turns out b
is through a bomb that is correct
my bad in all fairness if you would
if you had thrown the jar it would have
killed me too
oh my [ __ ] god this is the craziest
sandwich i don't know if i should be
trying to eat this on stream holy [ __ ]
you eating some kind of crazy sandwich
it's a sandwich made out of like chicken
tinders
that sounds incredible no like it
it's a giant bun with coleslaw and sauce
and pickles and then like three giant
chicken tinders inside it
whoa i don't like the spiders what is
this gold
sort of mask gonna do is that gonna [ __ ]
me up
oh if you pick that up it's like a trap
but you can if you're fast enough you
can take
oh jeez yeah just keep eating your
sandwich dude it'll keep us alive for a
long time i'm gonna wipe my hands
we'll look like pro gamers yeah we'll go
spit at each other
nice nice
this is the most romantic thing i've
done in months
oh holy [ __ ] this [ __ ]
you know what i you know i've heard many
many about spelunkies but i just
i didn't expect this it's me
beautiful it's a beautiful beautiful
game there's a lot there's just so much
going on
well i know when uh affliction best
friend finished it
he was like extremely excited about
having finished it and i was like yeah
we all finished video games man i don't
really understand what your point is
i did dad last week too but i have no
right now i kind of get it
it looks like oh i remember oh
whoops okay we'll get those hamster
kisses
the key unlocks the special item that is
then oops all right
another talking about the lasagna thing
have you guys seen the lasagna thing
my chat just mentioned it the rusty
lasagna situation let's see
yeah all day did rooster tea started or
did someone else start it
eric boujoir started it yep
who's that he started it and it's never
ending he's roman 64.
got it okay thank you i'm back so so i
feel like i feel like it's
it's too lasagnas yeah i agree
if you prepare two things separately and
then put them on top of each other they
do not just become one thing
it's pretty sound logic right yeah that
i mean
that's the whole argument is are two
lasagnas
one lasagna no no it's too lasagnas
i just think that don't eat my sandwich
but then if you put two rabbinars on top
of each other it probably does become
one carbonara
no if they're prepared separately oh i
don't know
i don't know that one's tough oh no i
left my turkey behind
all right let's go beat this level on
okay pro gamer
oh that seems fast those of you watching
my stream you might want to switch to
another one
for like 10 minutes oh no so the problem
is like not only is this game
absurd but i'm also really bad at
platforming
um it's a known issue that i have in my
life
oh my god maybe not made to spelunk
is what happened jacob how do i watch
youtube how do i move to
oh you just kind of when you're a ghost
you kind of get stuck with one person um
i'm going to try and break this ghost
face to just [ __ ] jacob
oh no no oh my god i did it i didn't go
oh i did it i didn't think i'd be able
to do it as a ghost
a lot of the ghosts i could we can't
john the ghost is coming for you is he
you're the only one left will he keep
coming
yes i can hear him don't worry don't
worry about it
alana we could spit on it okay yeah
let's put on the ghost this is what i
always do
oh it's two guys what the [ __ ]
oh my controller's covered in grease now
how about the two of them you need to
get one of those pubg grease free
controllers
oh i can't spit on these ghosts left to
the left
no i can't spit on either of them oh
they look happy though oh
you hate to see it realized the boss was
still alive
it was i was too scared how did that
happen who who knows who knows you know
uh nobody is aware of who is at fault
for that happening so
basically every single disaster can be
traced back to me somehow
i don't know about that okay i think
yeah
i think you're innocent on this one mate
oh dad he's gonna come back
leave his belly button his belly button
don't let it touch you it's a mamma name
pick up the skull and then i throw the
skull at him
oh you got him he's dead you killed him
oh a lotta
i'll leave that there i'll take this
yeah i did take some cool stuff
oh look at me go i just having a nap
[ __ ] i think i'm stuck in this pit
though with your corpse
yeah you might be i gotta oh that's a
shame
how do you use the rope you look i'm
married
whoa no oh jacob go jacob and my buddy
go it's right
i'm good i'm good i'm alive
oh oh okay here's little poop beetles oh
my god
good great yeah we had two thousand
dollars i've been raising money um this
month but color of change and i wasn't
looking and we just hit two thousand
dollars thank you everyone oh that's
awesome oh yeah
congrats it's the sacrificial pillar
let me check the donations
i want to sacrifice this turkey good
thing this song is nice
where you can get get out of here
well i want to see something [ __ ] up
absolutely follow
always okay hang on hang on no
tab in video
it's a little turkey just whipped him up
a little bit
jacob that's [ __ ] up are you like
i live up to my promises oh my god jacob
this is what i do that's what i do
that's what i do
oh look how much of a cool guy you are
this look is cool when i do it
oh my speakers are on hey what's up and
have been the entire stream yeah what's
up
what's up oh yeah but for me i'm doing
i'm doing
[Music]
wet ass p word what else p
oh this is a gross rat let's just get
out of that what did you call me
look a belly button person no i was
definitely talking about you i think you
threw him on me
well maybe it was my fault probably
john's just gonna stay he's just gonna
stay there because he left right that's
okay we're just gonna finish this level
whatever oh
brilliant beautiful love to see it see
john knew we could do it
i'm back i want to say thank you too
justin
robbed he and michael yeah i think i'll
just just donate it thank you matthew
terrier
thanks for continuously killing it with
charity work you're great the community
is amazing
i agree you're pretty
i tried to get the happy meal pokemon
cards and i got uh hasbro instead
goes face uh at this perfectly in sync
we're like mario and luigi yeah
not known for being in sync really
you mean you're more like uh justin
timberlake and any other member of that
band
yes wonderful do they the others have
names i don't know
no no kevin
aleister oh i broke the face and there
was a skeleton
oh
john smith on the case
here we go speed run oh
people do speed around this game right
like what are the conditions what are
the win conditions
i don't know about the second one i
didn't know the physics for the jump
the first one the the most popular
speed run is like you have to get an
eggplant
which is rng related you get it from a
gif oh
oh yeah it's really weird
come on roll you big dummy droideka
there we go can you come spit on this
guy
oh i thought you'd never ask he's stuck
yes i am
oh no hang on in the wrong tab find
something to spit on foia
yep that's this one i gotcha who would
you huh you're not
john the big guy big guy
okay big guy oh i missed big guy
aim and spit well it i did but i guess
he was off screen
which is pretty rude here we go this is
the one that's the one
oh my god oh my god oh my god
babe nice yeah i got the eel which way
should we go
uh let's go to the non-lava okay
although that one is just as dangerous
oh i'm sorry i thought it was just gonna
go
somewhere else also i think we lost we
missed the
[Music]
oh my god what happened what happened
dad think about that
each other it's fun
oh god
i like to think that it's not a sad face
it's a mustache
what just happened to you john he was
the last second though
there may have been a bat there may have
been a bat that i didn't
may have been involved oh
do you guys want to know my opinion on
the one lasagna two lasagna debates yeah
desperately actually i could not give
less of a [ __ ]
that is fair i mean that's why i didn't
tweet about it but
that's a hot take john you know i don't
know why you need to bring all this
anger to the
lasagna situation listen it's semantical
[ __ ] oh i dropped the bomb watch out
everybody
it's like it's something i it's
something like
it's a hot dog a sandwich that's like
this dude it's like
shut the [ __ ] up i mean it's definitely
white people [ __ ]
i'll give you that i want charlotte
showed us this like
someone oh my god that i was kind of
like i
i thought it was all [ __ ] oh a lot
look out for the rack
i'm really scared of breaking your vase
it sounds very precious
you left behind her bombs oh no not a
lot of
bombs yeah i loved those we're gonna
need those we are
before oh [ __ ]
turkey turkey oh
take that bat nice
golden um what did charlotte show you
thanked me
it was like a powerpoint about why it
was about like
certain seafoods being a cube or
something
yeah it was a food cube of like
directing of how different foods are
defined
and so nice
[Music]
so what certain foods are defined a
certain way if they are cube shaped or
something
all right no no the cube was like the
different sides of like
uh that define it um
the cube there was no food that's
actually cubes
it was a food cube like a food pyramid
and all i can remember is that they
claimed that steak was a salad
yep what it was like a like a corn dog
was a cat was a california it was a
calzone a corn dog was a calzone
it and it was it was literally it was
very obviously just a troll to infuriate
people right yeah i was like oh i got oh
no oh the hamster immediately died
the systems there are a lot of systems
and i keep wanting to take this pug but
i don't know what the incentive is other
than it is a cute dog
it gives us one health at the end it
gives you a kiss
it gives you a kiss gives you a health
back nice kisses
yep by the way ours
our pug is actually set to a hamster so
we're seeing hamsters
yeah duh oh the best dodge i've ever
done in my life
i'm alive again oh i didn't know you
could move the those stones
yeah only the gray ones we can go
through the end john if you're not
oh i thought i hit him kill me that was
stupid
no i shouldn't have ordered a giant meal
in the middle of a stream
i disagree you still got progress to
make on it oh yeah
oh yeah i'm like halfway through the
sandwich and none of my fries have been
eaten
nice i have a problem of usually
starting with the fries because i like
fries so much and then not eating the
other actual expensive things i bought
what i'm like i ate the fries second
i like to eat them in canned chicken
[Laughter]
oh
that was the quickest death yeah
i'm not proud
and then straight into the spikes come
back speedy boy
i would like to freeze you ah nice
i can't get that that guy oh the pug
here baby oh here we go
i'll try i'll get it down with this you
have a net
or a rope there you're right
we definitely need that health oh yes i
have
one heart left hopefully you can make it
oh yeah look at all that gold look at
all that gold oh
gold
you baby me to freeze bat i will freeze
back nah we're good we made it
then now to die in lava
yep a torch so were you saying before
that you had like choices with the
way you could go at this point or
something yeah you can go left or right
and one
this is the lava land and then there's
forest land on the other side
jacob what happened i did that i didn't
kill jacob but i did do that
i said i'm not gonna give that to alana
that was all me
all right wait wait wait wait wait how
did you guys looks in here did i do it
i don't think i did i've already
forgotten i think i fell in love
that may have been my fault who's that
guy
oh it's epidemic scrooge
hey buddy
[Music]
you're welcome i do not know what i
saved you from but
he may have hurt you with well you're
down even more
nice oh there's cold down there nice
we're safe in here treasure where'd my
key go
oh i guess i used it on the chest
well spent oh well metal roof and it's
not a door
that why is that not at all and i don't
[ __ ]
oh no oh okay can you get stuck
yes you can very much so oh
it's very dark in here oh does it help
when i flash
violently yeah can we flash does that
cause lights for you
yeah we flash you john sure that works
you know no one's gonna have seizure
right
oh maybe
get that robot oh who built this
yeah that's a great question what were
they thinking
oh look it's a lot of uh well that was a
gathering of resurrection
oh
we made it yeah i can't believe we made
it we made it
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] damn you got a lot of money in
there
get that cold follow me sorry
what the [ __ ] jacob oh sorry hey
i feel like you might be doing this on
purpose oh no
no nice what happened
get the dog i picked up the dog
alana you want to ride this fire dog oh
doctor i mean to fight
i do that what should i drop off you
just gotta jump on its back
okay uh just chill for a second
well that's what happened to me when i
tried to do that
jump don't do it again no okay maybe
this time one more try one more try
just want him to just turn in the other
direction go down there
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i wanted
to try if you have a friend
oh god i have a ghost friend now that's
cool yeah we can hang out be ghosts
help john not anymore oh i'm back
bye lana you're all you're wrong hey
look out
you deserve that that's that's oh
wow you didn't deserve all of that
just a little bit of that there's a gold
ball here you don't want this gold ball
huh i
deserved everything that happened yeah
we could make a case for that yeah
here we go the little running of the
animation is great
yeah onwards it is pretty cute
oh who's this oh yeah you can just push
that to the edge
[Laughter]
oh my gosh okay i'm back hello
oh fire there is a lot of fire out there
we're getting his four leaf clovers okay
oh jacob oh [ __ ]
well off we go oh [ __ ] hell okay
i just can't believe i'm alive just
happy to be out here living
yeah not my best life just a life look
at this guy this dog over here
how get off dog oh i wanted to get on
dog this problem
what is with that i'm a bit concerned
about that drill though
we need like a special key to turn out
okay
okay there you go a dog also shoots
fireballs
so you can double jump with dog oh look
at that
oh my god
i gotta eat my food do it do it
johnny's the food oh god
that was amazing get out of here snake
oh okay i enjoyed the my small fleeting
moment that i had with dog but um
yeah that's a good time here we are
getting that goop
where are you going with a dorad spider
we tried to find
out found a door beautiful beautiful
look at him
i'm sorry what good elbow blow ah
thank you there we go here we go oh
that webs got that arrow that almost
went to my chest oh jeez oh wait this
one with those
oh you guys died well the bat was there
right
was my logic i have no clue see i've
already forgotten what happened in the
last two seconds
that may have happened who knows what
yeah what do we do about this
um watch this
don't make it i did and i'm gonna get
this guy trigger the other one
nice okay
let's see what this they stay they stay
triggered right
yes it's only one shot beautiful
oh yeah also don't piss off the
shopkeeper noted
because he will murder us and once you
aggro one shopkeeper all npcs moving
forward
are all aggressive damn yeah and they
have guns
they have shotguns okay
that's a lot to unpack oh there was a
key there
oh it's fine we probably didn't need it
it's fine we don't need it
never do i don't know what we need just
in general
um see it was right there before i
left i saw it damn it
nice it escaped
oh the turkey man i don't give a [ __ ]
200 gold about that
it's probably not gonna happen i'm a
ghost now
oh i didn't mean to do that oh no oh
you're fine you're good
spit on this man yeah watch this we're
helping oh
watch that is that what you wanted us to
watch i was trying to murder the turkey
i'm sorry i just meant to hit that pot
whatever i like it
you in a pot a very difficult teleport
common problem everybody's been saying
it jacob looks like a pot and likes to
be awake
like a lovely boss i've got i've got
curves like a vod exactly you look like
a fox
did i make it that was dick you did [ __ ]
alana come here come here okay yeah
what's up
watch this watch this
nice he's dead that's okay that's a
choice
wait what killed me did you just kill me
i didn't even see how i just died i
didn't mean to do that did you kill him
oh my gosh
get back here well get back here i'll
just smash everything
you
even this man
you know you're too fast i can't catch
you get that oh my
shield yours is a spider in it nice
oh that's the worst picking something up
and there's a [ __ ] spider in it
tell me about us my childhood fam you
don't even know
oh god okay
okay i'm breaking everything i'm not
i'm not picking anything up i'm just
crushing all of the items
dude get that hammy
why did i smoke
what would any of us really do that's
true i probably would have done the same
thing
except yeah give crotch to punching
exactly
gotta get you kicked somehow man it's
hot in the pandemic
i'll we're desperate we'll take nearly
anything
check my edge
oh no okay
watch this look that's all gross a
little belly treading on these men
okay so you have to drop the hamster off
at i tried to throw the hamster at the
door
oh no
oh you threw this dude else over there
he just wants somebody to stick a finger
in his belly button ow
there's a mall run yeah get away from
the ball i'm all scary
i mean we're just we're at the end
anyway yeah okay
got that hamster kiss cool
i [ __ ] dunked on that snake oh yeah
look at this how do we how would we get
that key when it's behind you
pick x oh i can do that
yeah do it [ __ ]
[Applause]
there actually is an item that turns
your bombs into stick i just expected it
to
amazing i'm stuck in this hole
yeah but it was like yeah bomb shaking
what would you rate it i
oh yeah i do wait should i have all the
ghost faces in the bomb
no oh
oh look at that i have one heart again
uh
shopkeep dude we died right okay cool
yeah yeah
is this a hulk hand spectacles
mitt rope climbing gloves
oh man oh man oh an arrow
oh my god
hey jacob's ghost hi no no no no
no it's okay could you freeze him
the what yeah
no i can't get up there i would like to
get to the turkey section
i see the hole i see the hole what'd you
call the first special
special reward for a key
yeah let's get in that hole nice
nope this is not the right hole yeah i
know that
uh what is this this is a pointless hole
should i not have done that no okay
now that we're alone we're that stay
comfortable
i'm sorry i'm sorry that i brought us to
this cave
where is i don't know
where am i there i am i'm just trying to
get back out of this cave
okay we've done it my gosh
all right there's the end well i guess
we don't need this key
oh my god what happened i just ran into
one of the lizards
nothing you know that was so difficult
i love that when people die the ghosts
like flip onto camera
yeah yeah
nice i almost hit that pot you almost
hit that ghost face
nice nice it's me oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh
all right lana spit on this man spitting
on the man say it
i already did it uh right
well we have bombs yeah we got three
bombs oh jesus
oh what do you need bombs three bombs i
have zero
are we stuck down here no no no no now
we're good there we go
look at that look at that
i can't go through okay here you go on
your way so i can keep turkey
okay i can't go that way give me a gold
bug
give me a gold bug i can't get it
i'm gonna eat these cold fries here i'll
go to the end
see you guys out here talking about
french toast
all right but why don't
all right we're in lava town
i don't like this shotgun
yeah he's uh not always our friend not
is for
sometimes he is your friend
not those ones those ones are like
guarding treasure or something
yeah those are up to no good
oh i'm trying to freeze you okay yeah
he's alright
i got a compass
oh nice
sniped it oh firebug
all right alana you're coming back oh oh
okay
hit me i am back and there are bats
oh i got it that was beautiful okay i'm
going to try to throw a bomb
without killing dog okay
okay that's a good bomb
unfortunate let's get out of here
you win some heaven
you win some uh sometimes other things
happen oh the devil
there's a hamster up there
that's the other cool thing about this
game alana is that there's so many
secrets
[ __ ] oh
the pothole spider in it oh no yeah that
happens sometimes rude
oh wait can i do this oh my god
so wait are the levels are the levels
the same as we're going through them
no they're procedural i just feel like
i'm recognizing some
patents but it's probably just the the
design i dropped my lava pot
oh i found a gold guy run run i mean
there there might be like
certain structures that pers that like
are part of the
a lot of drawers oh boy oh oh that oh
oh that that's lava physics boys oh geez
oh oh god i could have been stopped for
a long time that's okay
we have 33 000 look out look out for
that guy get it
oh get out of my way drill oh whoa they
explode
yeah jump on their heads hit the button
on their heads
what are these
like what do they do oh that's what they
do jerks why is everyone a jerk yeah
it's a ladybug it shoots fire where are
you
spiderman oh no it's minor
i'll take this
no
oh my god you just melted dude
melted that was actually that was
actually what happened
wait what i i died from fall damage and
dropped alana's body of the lava
that was me that burned oh rude now my
family can't even say goodbye
challenge oh there's a cremation what is
the moon challenge
i just wait for that to go away i guess
can we push that i did this one before
oh cool those are force fields race
shields
oh yeah i did do this one before
nice nice cool nailed it all right let's
go easy chill
get that picture yeah no i totally did
this one my first time
thanks for illuminating it for me yeah
no worries bro welcome
who are we helping we helping
i'll do some tricks oh look at you doing
flips
you almost throw the pickaxe at yourself
there's so many skulls
yeah i got a compass
you think we go this way it looks like
it look at that
diamond nice ruby or whatever good haul
good haul yeah i think maybe i don't
have a challenge
well done this currency is made up to me
so what do i [ __ ] know
wait oh i think i have to end
just keep going probably until the timer
ends
or is there where is there screen no it
just lasts a certain amount of time okay
we're helping
oh that could have been bad oh that was
a closed one
challenge complete oh yeah it's when the
pickaxe breaks
oh right right right right nice did we
do good i got an achievement
we do good right [ __ ] you
uh we just hit
2124 hell yeah
thanks to those donations we are going
to start over so
uh struggling with giving what i can no
not as a result just
in honor of the donations
as well there actually isn't a way to
support the podcast we we donate persons
in honor of charity
but maybe they will be eventually i
don't know taco cup also donated 20
years
oh poor jacob i'll carry you to the end
yeah take that with you
take that home okay oh no throw me in a
bat
nice your corpse will serve a great
purpose
i am the dead
what happened to you jacob i thought i
could slide under him there is a spider
or something
uh that checks out this game's evil
spider in my shower this game is evil oh
dude give us little licks that's penis
yeah little smooches
sick flips bro it's good for morale
yeah what's the key doing
a coffin i want to spit on myself
nice nice jacob
is there a like a tidy waiter
a tidy way to jump down uh
if you you can jump from ledge grab to
ledge grab
so say you're at like a high ledge but
you see that
directly below you there's another ledge
if you just drop straight down
from your grab you'll just grab onto the
edge without
damage
[Music]
i learned that on accident
hey i took the puzzle look at the final
level yeah
we got full health yeah bro poke with us
oh not today i've never had full health
before this camp oh in the hole
that's a spider that's a scale oh the
spikes it like it's
really sliding over that god damn
whatever
whatever i like it okay i don't know how
to get out of here
so i don't i'm watching john in the cave
right now so
you're on here what is happening with
all of these holes
maybe i want the whole i want the glory
hole not the
these freaking holes i got it i got it i
got it
right next to the hole with a freaking
treasure chest
get away from me you stop stupid bat
uh-huh i got him
ow why didn't you hurt me he was asleep
okay bubble here watch this nice jacob
[Music]
hello belly button man
it really does look like he has an anus
for a belly button has anyone ever told
him that do you think do you think he's
had that before
i think it's interesting i'd like to
stick my finger in it
he looks like he's related to a diglett
cousins or something he's like one of
those alternate evolutions where you
hold the button down or flip your
ah he's a mega evolution alolan whatever
whatever oh my god
i may have died oh no oh no
it's up to you alana okay well
i don't feel great about it there you go
uh all right well was that bat or back
uh bat i keep doing it because of um
because of this is too many things from
home
um what we do in the shadows
okay he's dead that guy's dead i killed
him
can i use him to trigger the trap you
can uh yeah you don't have to go up
though you're right that's true you just
okay nice is he that's the exact same
thing that happened to me i forgot to
tell you
how did that kill how did that kill us
oh it's a long drop
yeah yeah i see yes you broke your
kneecaps
that's tight i love that for me yeah
that's pretty cool honestly
yeah brilliant i'm gonna get a spider
john nope there's a rat
nope all the spider-man
oh despite hip map it's what he said
and those were his final ones i'm still
alive for now
give me five minutes snake [ __ ]
oh no i'll save you oh no it's in the
ghost face oh [ __ ] you did too
oh it's right here oh god
where's the exit oh it's not this way
it's not that way it's not that way it's
not that way
right oh
fine it's fine it's fine it's fine i
tried to help by throwing the ghost face
at a steak
i appreciate that you got rid of the
snake though that really meant a lot
thank you
yeah nice
hey buddy hold on my hands are covered
in
sauce yeah that's that's real game and
[ __ ] dude i don't even play video games
unless i'm holding sauce anymore
i got one of them halo skulls cool
you trying to get that grunt birthday
party or something yeah
oh it's trap nice nice
is that the exit i'm smart you're done
doing it
there's the ghost face i want to see
what's in this this hole here
hello hole hello coming in
i'm recording this gameplay and it's
going to be mostly just
like my character's standing there are
you eating a sandwich
yeah and you guys talking with your
little like pointers
rolling around on the edge of the screen
all right we're back in it baby i would
like to come back to life
we'll find that coffin that'll be tough
i'll dig you up i'm cleaning my hands
i'm cleaning my hands
let me ride this turkey all done you're
my friend now
now i just get to drink my horchata and
game
hell yeah do you dream baby it's me
it is uh by the way firebirds in san
diego
is bomb as [ __ ] firebird bugs that's the
name of the uh australian netball team
that's probably how you know what jacob
australian nipple team
oh yeah that of course um
i never look at them cheese it didn't
kill me though okay that's good that's
good that's good we like it we like
mlg there's about to be mlg up in this
[ __ ] look at all the what does the
salamander do
oh it's an axolotl i apologize to you oh
the ox a lot of blows bubbles
yeah should i buy it i'm friends with it
write it should i buy it
yes i bought it i can now ride it
oh my god it both boobles
oh my god this is the best did you try
to get my corpse john
yeah i believe in you i don't know where
to go though no no
no no no no no no no no
okay so everything went wrong cool oh
[ __ ] my actually i was trying to
sacrifice
your corpse to the god of death so yeah
yeah bring your your axolotl to the end
there
isn't he cute isn't that like that he's
the cutest thing i've ever seen in my
life oh the end's right there
oh what the what he teleports oh i think
you picked up a teleport item maybe
oh should i should i leave did you press
y press y
no
oh my gosh i love him
that panic teleport was pretty close i
don't know how that happened yeah
however it happened oh all right good
luck
i got [ __ ] all over my pikuniku shirt oh
no
okay this is this yep i know i keep i
keep accidentally jumping off
because they always pulled up
well that time tell us a different
teleport teleport killed me
um yeah it betrayed you immediately wow
no polana you there's a scorpion in
there this is the rhinolana
god do the platforming in this game
i'm just not used to it oh that's a
poisoned arrow
oh hey jacob why are you all green i'm
poisoned you're right
oh buddy are you okay oh heck all right
john it's all you bud it's all you you
got you got it
i walked so john could run yep
there you go hey guys i have five hearts
hell yeah
all right i i finished my meal in the
nick of time hell yeah yeah we really
need you
you're gonna solo this right now i'm i'm
here
oh yeah i'm also back yes
let's see how long that lasts give me
about 30 seconds
uh so i found the ghost face is right
there but it's
covered we'll see about that oh i have
no bombs
do i have moms b bombs b bombs x i don't
know
i ain't got no bumps oh you don't have
any oh
and i've got hiccups all right well why
are you stuck here then i guess just
hang out
well don't don't push up don't leave
don't leave
no leaving i've got a oh wait hey
what no what's up
[ __ ] [ __ ] you wanna wanna do some
purchase
yeah there's two rows hanging out and
doing push-ups
hell yeah don't worry about it because
we can literally
not get out of this pit is that the is
that the hole
we live in this is a hole it's the hall
what kind of the realization we all
dream of oh
what kind of hole i just see that
shotgun man over there still he's up in
the corner
yeah what's his hole like i bet it's
real nice
[ __ ]
no hamster sorry guys i'm
i'm stuck in doing my own thing i'll be
over there in a moment
it's okay it's okay all right i got an
item
hopefully if we get to level two or
world 2 or whatever you will
we can i think we'll be able to make
that drill but i'm not
entirely sure and duking we could give
you 20 thank you
uh raising money for change it's um
basically the largest online racial
justice organization in the us
coming in like i'm coming your way this
month
yeah yeah halfway through the month i
got we're all separated
from the goal i think you guys are 500
tonight that'll be pretty tight that's
all i'm saying
currently at 2194
yeah oh i'm back hello oh look out oh
the trap
i saw this one do we have uh
wanna don't no i will not wha are you
what is the green that's coming from
your butt
there it is oh wait oh boy those i have
spring boots
cool it lets me drop three squares
instead of two that's neat
oh also if you come with the spikes from
the side without jumping you can just
run through
what i didn't know that yeah
i want to get to that that one oh but i
did two but i jumped down instead
no
trying to but i don't think i can
oh my god
oh sorry he's hitching my own eye i'm
alive i'm live
where are you guys at having all these
adventures well i'm off on my own look
out jacob
oh it's because your spring boots make
you so fast dude nice
how are we supposed to adventure with
someone that's that speedy
hi kitty kitty's playing under my bed
oh heck okay i'm at the end we're good
we're good oh i did like freaking
beautiful beautiful beautiful frigging
mitch
flower power moves up and down that's
what i was gonna say he's playing right
now
he's having a good time she's having a
good time
look out for trap
this is my favorite song
all right all right one of you needs to
die so that we can freeze the
rude there you go
wait hold on we gotta send him the other
way because the trap for the
where'd he go uh what the
what i think he blew up really he
explode
he'll get the hamster down for you
why do you keep calling it a hamster
it's clearly a pug i don't
know it's a you can look at it oh that's
right for you guys it looks like a
hamster sorry i haven't gone i figured
if i go it's my bad
all right we gotta go to the right okay
cause i have a special item
okay it's all you chief
i'm just hanging out here with my pug
nice jacob nick
oh my god oh my god oh my god okay yeah
i might just
cut our losses against that door hair
losses
no i threw the pug
get a hamster
[ __ ] pug hamster hamster hamster
hug
okay cool great
jacob i totally planned that
beautiful okay all right now we just
have to get to like world
or zone two
who could this be oh yeah
watch this watch this watch this
oh my gosh that was scary it was pretty
cool
down there the lava is rising up above
okay okay okay oh that what does the
sacrificial table thing actually do
question uh you can get an item if you
put enough living or dead bodies there
that's [ __ ] up
you know what i'm not going to stray too
far from the door i oh god there's that
oh there's a lava down there oh boy look
out
hmm there's the hamster is there
oh oh boy the hamster
died where it spawned and we had nothing
to do with it that's a shame
mm-hmm no my problem is at the door yeah
here we go yeah go go go there's a lava
what the [ __ ] jacob
there's a fire ladybug nothing to do
with that
i'm innocent oh lana
oh alana i thought it was you john i
thought that it was you
i was just looking at your character and
i was like it'll be great it'll be great
i got i got a hamster oh wait there's a
drill
oh oh my god this is the moment
is this gonna work i hope
oh what's that what's happening it's a
tree
where did it where did it go can i climb
this chain
a good question you can but it goes to
lava
this seems like a risk but get to it
because i'm stuck down this seems like a
risk mate
uh i'm gonna wait for the lava to
dissipate can i freeze it
i'm stuck i got no ropes
will the lava eventually dissipate is
that how lava works yeah the lava really
the the water fit or the liquid physics
in this yeah
maybe here we go i'm going
oh god how's it going over there i mean
he's doing great where is this
taking us yeah i don't know
here take the hamstring oh you just it
just took you real low turns out oh my
god
oh no what happened that's stuck
oh no well i could go through the exit
okay dang it now we go
we're gonna
wait for the next lava drop to fall and
then i'll jump because i don't want to
jump and get hit by a lava drop
and then the lava from the immediate
oh god i'm not good at this
who's it gonna be oh don't jump on me
i almost did i almost was just like i
want to help this person be alive
oh [ __ ] balls oh what
happened
[Laughter]
broken some records i think for sure
sure
oh our old enemy and his belly hey maybe
freezing could help you
he's handsome oh it's uh what did i say
yeah look it's me
oh
i don't like this one turns out i can't
freeze him devastating
i don't like this i don't like this i
don't like this nice jake great doing
great doing great
this is the way this is the way
oh oh golly nice
go all right run to the right run to the
right the right oh it's titties
what the heck i'm crazy we're going to
crab world
oh my god special crab world oh yeah oh
oh it's the coolest thank you for the
race
oh well i thought there was a gap there
but there
wasn't look out
uh i was saying that we would love to
have 2500 tonight that was super cool
i had to press my keyboard to talk to
the chat and this is how you played me
oh maul
[ __ ] look out there's trap look how
there's trap there is trap you're right
earth trap
whoa nice nailed it yeah good job
nice get back to his face we want
the money give me the gold money i want
the gold
[Applause]
oh i tried this oh
okay okay okay okay okay
beautiful that was speeding
[Music]
there's a boomerang
no i don't want to [ __ ] with you don't
no i don't want anything to do with you
oh you have a chance oh [ __ ] did you die
no oh buddy
[Music]
nice john oh gosh
what's going on down there i think i'm
above you
i think this is the right
you [ __ ] get away from me you stupid
lizard
hi let's get john has modern firearms on
his side now
oh that i do okay shall we
shall we bounce let's do it
let's oh wait
all right well let's go wait did i shoot
you alana yeah you sure did but you sure
you sure [ __ ] did
wow i assumed i assumed it was me that
did that somehow
oh oh it's a shopkeeper he's mad
freeze himself keep him spit on him spit
on that old man why is he mad freeze the
shotgun
i'm sorry sorry i killed his brother no
that's fair actually
maybe i'm on his side come back do it
take him all shotgun him
oh oh nice the dog oh you killed our
hamster
killed the hamster too well we're wanted
men now
look at that and alana we're armed to
the next
i'm [ __ ] okay reminder alana a little
pro tip
don't open the coffin with a shotgun
yeah it doesn't go great
no tid did it for the person in the
coffin noted
look out oh my god wow that was already
triggered somehow oh god oh god i'm gone
okay how did you add how did you even
get away from that
i don't know if you fall it just isn't
that much of a joke
is that the case because you can move
yeah sometimes you can fall past it
oh sorry about that was my bad
he's the old man oh take the gun take
the gun there's a third guy
we all have shotgun now that's great for
us i'm sure that'll be fine
how to pick up oh i didn't pick it up oh
no no
damn it i'm sorry it's okay so sorry
you may have saved our lives though i'm
about to that's true
most of us kill each other with shotguns
as you are well aware yeah that is true
that did happen to me
oh my god oh that's ghost face
i don't want that
nice look at their eyes on fire look at
all the punching get out there oh
i couldn't get up in time oh i got both
of those
oh [ __ ] okay i gotta get it i gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta
gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta get
it i guess
we gotta get back snake bit me and threw
me into punchy
yup i can't see oh oh yeah i can help
you with that
ow i can't help you everybody would
break i can't help you with that
i can't help you with anything that's
happening here okay all right you got
one health left jacob
oh oh buddy um about that jacob you got
hate to see it wow [ __ ] happened to me
he took care of those trap i never
[ __ ] look at them
okay let's get down let's get down go
back gotta hit no
the bat leave me better
[Music]
this music pleasant game
oh sorry no my hamster
oh god spider
naked
oh my god what the [ __ ] what happened
i don't know i was just one minute i was
alive at one minute i was dead
i don't know how it happened oh my god
there are many times where playing this
solo where i've died and i go
i have no idea what just happened yeah
thank you uh mountain duke and i
appreciate that oh thank you
okay he's friendly again not good hey
thank you for 2003
everyone that's amazing guys there's a
shotgun and an
x-ray gun over here or there's a
crossbow and a gun over here if you want
it's also a frozen title
yeah oh
i'm coming back oh
okay oh that's like an ice gun that's
cool
yeah that's a nice gun the crossbow you
have to keep collecting the arrow right
yes okay but i will not do that climb
down look at my little legs go
yeah the way she grind that pole
oh
my god
[Laughter]
well hey elana there's an ice gun right
here yeah that's crazy
oh my god where did this come from
sorry jacob oh [ __ ] we got a
a a prompt demonstration of why
okay so how to shoot with shotguns well
yeah what yeah actually through my
intervention the coffin was not involved
at all
well this is actually a pretty accurate
representation of uh
how guns are supposed to work in real
life so like if you own
one that statistically you're more
likely to shoot someone you know yeah
i shouldn't have been standing down
range like that that's a no-no
it helps all right oh i thought that
actually hurt you but it didn't
punches yeah i'm trying to avoid
punchies
we got it we got it we got it we got it
yeah got that gun oh nice shoot that man
oh he got shot by
everything is that trump been triggered
already
yeah yeah
do you need me to open the coffin who is
this guy should i talk to him
he's the people yeah so that guy if you
bring all the turkeys in the
level to him he'll give you a key for
that little door down that's too much
oh jonathan
what he's mad interesting
i think he's stuck up there now because
they can't climb ladders
because he's old nice yeah he was
standing by the exit and he shot me in
the face
great no no he can't do you he
absolutely can
just forgot for a second i guess
been climbing ladders my whole life jump
in that trap
nice jacob dumb spider
ah i can't make this jump ever [ __ ]
i can't ever make this [ __ ] it's a trap
right there you can make it never
every time
i'm not sure how the jump physics work
yet you know what i'm saying
i gotcha jesus is there a tiny man
he came out and just like posed real
quick
he was very pleased about it and i will
be a light
there we go never mind i'm very slow you
didn't need it
just spit on me all right the garden's
going to be guarding this
right jacob all right here watch this
i'm gonna oh wait
hold on yeah i'm freezing my freezer
what [ __ ] no it's a bat though you
prematurely didn't freeze him
spit hard on damn it oh he's so movement
spit on him damn it
harder there we go there you go he has
been spat upholst
i have on him oh no what are we left
with
this is cool i'm
oh wait i do want his gun oh he's
already freezing hang on yeah i can't
see him
oh i'm going okay
what the glasses do
we're about to find out houses the x-ray
glass out
monkey
i hear another angry shopkeeper
somewhere i don't like it
could be right off the spectacles
improves your vision and also makes you
look slightly more intelligent
okay well that doesn't tell me anything
also i was already wearing them hey guys
how's it going i'm a ghost again
oh what jacob how did you die that's not
important yeah it's fair
i could just spit on people now though
yeah it's good
ow spike oh other ghosts
are the little tiny spikes well they
still hurt you these ones like yeah yeah
oh wow they give you one little
one little poke of damage might have
been involved in my death yeah
oh look out look out oh my god i thought
i was still
mechanics right i think that's how i've
died so many times
like i don't even realize really what's
happened oh there's a shotgun there
you're just happy to be alive
i'll get it out of the spikes here oh
can you do that
that'd be neat that means grab it grab
it
yeah you can still walk your face into
them gotcha very easy to do that
act as though they are cacti yes
understood
look at this smoochy plant it's a kiss
do not try to jump on him
ah nothing to do with that
that is debatable oh look at this guy
look at his cubesat
what is he the enemy oh my god you need
to calm down
before you need to calm down so you uh
oh that goes
good oh god i'm sorry john
all right let's spit on this damn it
damn it
oh this despite it the big spiders oh my
gosh
he has been spat upon oh nice
here it goes
you're cursed what happened what just
happened he cursed you
oh luke cursed me the ghost the floaty
ghost
what is this man it's like a big muscle
i do not like him he's a guy you can
hire but i guess if he's in the shop
when you when you're wanted he looks
like carl pilkington
is gonna be it's gonna be
may oh oh no first oh night you okay
hang on i can freeze this
god where did i go where am i where is
my okay hang on oh that ghost
yeah spit on him trying to go so curse
you
we have 40 000 gold and we can't spend
on anything because we're wanted
live how long will we be you took a
[ __ ] risk
how long will we be wanted for is this
how until we
start a new run oh
i'm sorry i was trying to pick up the
boomerang hang on hang on let me give
you the gun back and then take this okay
oh cool here here we go
oh no john so the shotgun s recoil
keep that in mind yep
okay
oh no oh that one's gonna have it too
okay i'm scared you'll have a second you
can get past it i believe
nice spectacles oh and
john's a sack i have like five bombs
should i land on it or is that gonna
kill me no
no it well it'll do one damage but you
know okay
okay we might need the hello i'm a ghost
i always forget that you become ghosts
i need to get lower huh
oh my god oh my god oh my god careful
alert i'm going in
no should we leave leave leave oh no you
got him nice
there's a jet pack over there what i've
had a bombs anyway so whatever okay
hi mama we do have so much money oh my
god there's already another shopkeeper
oh wow you're right john john john do we
have a situation he said hi
my horchata
nice oh [ __ ]
oh i shot the i just shot the wrong
person and then i
you shot me
you shout out dumb foundations
oh my god
[ __ ] hell this game's awesome this
game is really good
oh
pudgy butchy punches
[Music]
i was holding a vase and someone whipped
me
and it broke the vase which spawned a
snake
damn it yeah that was that was on me i
did that
[Music]
ugh
we made it alana we sure did we all made
it we all
made it to you i was not killed by my
friend
oh my god oh right jacob's here
yeah everyone's alive nice
nice sweet combo hey
hey oh boy
get in there get that hole that's a trap
i'm getting the item
the treasure okay maybe this time we can
get to the drill
that's true i bet we can i believe
oh me hello here wait jacob
yes i want to try something real quick
[ __ ] off snake
let me carry you i'm gonna try something
okay let's go okay
here let's try this oh i'm just trying
to spelunk
oh i found ghost face oh what the [ __ ]
that's john that's [ __ ] up that's f
you should apologize
that's the rudest thing i've ever heard
oh did it do anything
yeah alana come up here come up here i
can't i've died
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna sacrifice
you oh
yeah it literally shits gold out of it
oh my gosh
look at his little butt that's neat no
monkey
well oh god
[Laughter]
should have expected we're gonna we're
gonna oh i didn't get
alana's bombs it's okay we'll get back a
living person instead it's me
that's not good oh go look out
oh here yeah what do you think about
that oh
but that works too life
it's me can't believe we made it
we have to make it to the drill whatever
happens we will
we will so no killing each other okay
out
fat oops nice jacob hey
i did have the hamster but whatever
don't speed right now oh my god
oh my god i was just about to talk about
how many hearts we had
still what the [ __ ]
oh oh no good luck alana no it's okay
i'm alive oh [ __ ]
oh rolly boy wait get him to roll to the
right get him to roll okay we'll get him
all the right we'll go
and then we can just run we don't have
to kill him
you're a big boy oh [ __ ]
hold on you want to stay up you want to
stay okay stand up
okay oh oh okay i got it i wanna come
oh she's dead she's dead i am dead i am
i'm dead what happened
i just tried to fight a spider and it
knocked me back into belly button man
so valiant effort though here we are
we should all we all aspire to get hit
by the belly button man
we all a spider nice did you just try to
freeze me
no i was trying to provide you with
light my friend
all right we both have one health jacob
careful she'll spit on you
oh hey i'm back watch this
oh all right i'm scared i'm scared
oh wanna pick up that thing okay
what am i doing i don't know where to go
hold down hold down
you might if you put a rope up there i
love you
can i do i have a rope like up where i
am if you throw one right here
how do i no that's a dead
that's dead end right there i think
you're [ __ ]
hmm i have a bomb
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh i could definitely have used the ball
i'm sorry
oh i teleported into a wall i teleported
into the wall yeah the teleporting
does not does not pay off ultimately in
my opinion
very dangerous yeah it's terrifying oh
oh oh boy that's a big fault it's all
right
ah scale it let's get it oh
okay oh okay
the ghost the ghost and the punchies and
the snakes
the snake is in the worst place
oh my god what happened jacob
what i'm alive no i mean what happened
why did you break your face
[ __ ] bat oh i don't know son of a [ __ ]
it was very weird
oh
does that mean that we could just hang
on can i do that dark hell
not take the saint
oh my god what how did that happen so
fast it was a real
sonic the hedgehog oh damn it
whatever whatever well we're back and
we're gonna make it this is the run yeah
this is a milk run this is why we
finished the game right
this is a milk run oh yeah
oh hey i picked up some bombs i died in
seconds
yeah you're right it was like 20 seconds
okay
wait if i throw get up get up get up
damn it i don't really know what i was
supposed to do there
i threw my grappling hook up and it
damaged you alana
oh is that what happened yeah wild
everything is
is mean in this game they're almost at
2500
thank you everybody oh that's awesome
that is very good
that is a good time over again yeah
i saw an idol up there thank you to
snake derek you said great game a lot of
good and frustrating times
west of ireland oh cool uh anonymous
tunnels uh
i have not i see him 20 dollars here's
to the future pimple and freckles filter
pimple right here right here i also do
have the title
uh light uh uh
what just happened i'm reading donations
did you just kill me jacob may or may
not have sacrificed you to the jacob
god damn it to the jacob uh yeah i have
really
it's okay that you people think that i
love them
uh game attack thank you game attacks
thank you guys so much we are very close
to 2 500.
um a really big charity stream tomorrow
that'll be live from 2 p.m pacific
twitch.tv slash bright spot live it's
going to be a fun one
largely in person but super limited
we've got one health card looks like
we're disneyland close to each other but
it should be a good time i'm excited we
got two people one one turkey
oh nice oh my gosh am i here oh yeah you
have me
am i dead oh no you're riding a turkey
oh this is what i always wanted
jacob finally hi
the hamster it has died
[Music]
john are you serious you said trap's
already been trapped you thought i'd say
traps already been so i was like yeah
cool it's done and then and then that
happened
you jumped before i said that false look
out
that one was definitely my fault
not yet what the hell man what's the
corpse
okay now francis is a perfectly good
corpse you coming free him no
no let it roll let him roll oh
oh yeah let's just go all the way up
this way no he went on the left
he went to left it's this way he needs
to we don't have we don't have the
eyeball thing oh that's right i'm also a
ghost
oh okay did you drop anything
no i had nothing all right
oh
[Laughter]
my god jesus
hey that was fun thanks i love the
adventures it's a good time
yeah i really feel like i'm being social
[Laughter]
hey guys i went into a tunnel pretty
spooky
that was nothing i broke my ankles
and now i have a torch
[Music]
nice shape for once i do not damn jacob
you're wrecking house
i know i'm just slapping people left or
right even my own teammate
where the hell are we alana what's in
that cave
nothing i mean i guess i could have gone
down photo
but i did not oh
all right ah i dropped my torch i keep
getting attacked by things and yelling
the wrong thing
they all blur together
oh [ __ ] give me that gold yeah i feel
like i'm
like more focused about what's going on
here no john
johnny come here no get away from me
john
i'm not doing it it's not happening john
oh look should i pick up the shotgun and
kill the shopkeep
yes no damn it
oh god oh god it went bad uh who who
oh
just like in the movies take this key
and open his underground cavern
oh that frozen always wanted to see it
[Music]
i've entered the grandpa cave there's
nothing in here
nothing in there
well now i'm armed yeah i got killed at
the door
just like that just like that's that's
exactly what happened to me
we're not great at communicating
communicating unnecessary yeah yeah
okay that means the caters
immediately oh i panicked and now i am
i literally i looked at that and i went
that's the ghost face and then i
broke it oh i'm alive oh this is why
you're chaotic evil my dude
nice hey we have two thousand four
hundred and sixty nine dollars and funny
cents
nice thank you everyone
yep jacob i'm gonna give us some hearts
get us some
jacob did lawrence send you that um pick
of
of uh jaw-jaw having sex by any chance
this week
um no but i'm gonna have it i'm gonna
talk to him about that
i just assumed he would have sent it to
you he did he says to me star wars stuff
all the time what was the last
maybe you decided you would too before
it what what was it a drawing
no i took an animated picture if i
remember correctly
i guess that's a drawing technically
yeah
[Laughter]
don't worry about it what the [ __ ] just
happened
this [ __ ] oh my god
i want the diamond holy [ __ ]
with that sack nice well at least
oh my god let's see he sent me a picture
on a friday in december of the jar jar
lollipop
which i treasure that is a good one yeah
some star wars memes like deep cut star
wars memes
save all my friends hello hi
still not entirely sure how we died but
it was bad oh what the [ __ ] john
oh my god am i dead again i'm getting
out of the way yeah by throwing them
into me
it's fine it was a mistake i doubt
the turkey stop thank you alana yeah no
i got you guys that was intentional
oh what the [ __ ] happened
my cranium
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god it's fine
we're good oh oh
holy [ __ ] we were just skittering away
scurrying away look at the spider
oh it's over here all right
i just smashed buttons oh no
look at his donut whole mouth
just collecting gold balls don't let me
watch out for belly button
let's see
oh man i got myself stuck here is that
what i just did
you may be stuck oh no oh
but that's a shame okay that's okay it's
fine all right
nice we did it we did it we did it we
did it okay it just came out
we are nice you're watching five dollars
away from 2500 ladies and gentlemen
nice chat that's amazing i am very good
at this oh my gosh
oh no turkey yeah you are
oh man they're all it's turkey time
oh [ __ ] god
what again what what happened
last several minutes i've just not even
known what
did them that's okay oh my god dude
no oh buddy
buddy no it's a joke
oh that was close it was intentionally i
believe i believe
it's over there it's got to be over
there it is
oh that's a tricky one
[Laughter]
nice work oh jesus
don't chick i provide light
oh god oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
what was that it was a lizard it was a
rolling pin
the lizards just like roll around and
[ __ ] you up
do you all want to do like a couple more
yeah i uh i have my wife to do sadly
oh yikes oh yeah i can't believe we've
been going for two hours no this [ __ ]
snake yeah this game's
very easy to play for a long time yeah
it's it's fun every time despite it
being the worst thing i've ever played
in my entire life
this is as well as it's gone every time
yeah
isn't last time we got to the chinese uh
level like once i think we got there a
couple times we died pretty early on the
first time though in the second
oh yeah fish and we're just immediately
scared all right
we hit the giant fish right oh boy
oh there it goes and there
it goes i'll take this thank you
you're welcome afra is a snake oh no a
terrible chill
all right oh my god
that skeleton's alive i'm buying a
present
okay you got a present let me read them
let me read them
what's inside
yeah you should stay away from him yeah
he's he's
can i get myself back up freeze yourself
i want to get out of here
don't jon
[Music]
let's go we did it all
okay i feel like i don't want to get in
front of you
is the issue um if i could stay away
actually would be preferable
get it in that hole oh
jacob get it i'm gonna get it watch this
watch this watch this watch this
watch this watch this watch this
oh yeah that's right you need the key
for this i don't have a key for that
did somebody die is somebody dead no
boy jacob oh jacob
valerantly oh valerant death
you you let off the trap thingy didn't
you
that's what happened i i had it i had it
all played out in my head and it
just did yeah why is this level so deep
i like a good deep level oh [ __ ]
why did you say it like that you know
why he said it like what other way is
there to say it
you know
hmm hmm
what's going on up there i'm i'm in a
cave oh john
oh no oh it's a large cave
oh this is where you are why is this
cape so big
uh we're both dead oh my god there are
too many options in there okay
hurry if you go to the right no oh
there's a camera alana
buy the camera buy the camera okay be
the camera let's take pictures of us
take a picture being john
x
[Laughter]
yours is the best you like stick your
tongue out sloth face yeah
what do i got i can go through any of
these pick a hole eddie hole
cool oh alana's is the best one
oh wait here we go watch this oh the
yellow oh yellow
[ __ ] off [ __ ] i don't know what to do
you take a picture
all you can do is take pictures oh god
oh no take a picture
[Laughter]
all right how about this is the this is
the run we just said
thank you everyone this is the one if we
don't do it then we don't do it okay
oh sorry bud okay okay yeah that's my b
it's my b
ah it took a little bit of spill there
oh my god you saved me from that spider
dude
professional yeah you know what i'm
about i've been here before
i do i do this is my first time with
this rodeo
i believe that's that's the same thing
i have done this rodeo previously i'm
with this rodeo
oh no i'm stuck i have the hamster i
have the hamster i'll leave without me
okay don't come down here
uh well i am at the goal
we have a mission wait you have ropes
john but
i have a bomb
where's that oh god oh
oh oh oh oh oh hamster's dead
oh my god what happened let's get the
[ __ ] out of here whatever
[ __ ] it's the ride milk run baby look
out
go around go around that trap around
around the trap hamster
somebody get the pug
i fundamentally don't understand why
given the choice
either of you chose to make it a hamster
because we don't want to see a dog or
cat die
yeah and i mean i've seen i've
accidentally stepped on hamsters before
so like
i had a hamster once and it was like
that was a joke by the way
yeah yikes dude oh what the [ __ ] yeah
what was the circumstances
you sure did oh [ __ ] he's fine he's fine
he's fine
oh look there's gold down there wait let
me get it watch this one here
yeah let me touch it let me watch you
let me watch you do this i don't know
that this is oh my gosh
thank you for hit save me from the bat
okay and go
nice jacob i did it that's what was
supposed to happen last time
uh-huh well just pretend we didn't see
the first one it's fine
she did a buy something parachute
i need some bombs oh we got so much
money i'll just buy it all get it all
cool
buy that parachute jacob what's the
parachute you're going to do
i'll remember you parachute is like if
you're falling
if you're good at that damage it will
automatically open i think oh cool cool
cool
i have returned spot on with those
spider whips
not that one alarm wait what did i do
that i'm sorry
that's my bee i'm gonna get that compass
oh gosh
i'm gonna get the stuff no i got it i
got it i got it no i didn't did i get it
i think i have my corpse can you get my
corpse but but this is so much fun to
watch though
she's just repeatedly punching you it's
like
it's like those uh machines in super
mario maker 2 that they make
[ __ ] gold
[Music]
sorry bud i'm very wippy that's cool
yeah it works out well for me most of
the time a lot of men like it
it's the truth
all right big boy oh are you okay there
yeah i'm right
it's fine what's a scratch
come forth hedgehog man i dare ye god
damn it
why won't he roll roll like a droidica
please
huh he's jumping
i think maybe if you run the front like
you're running yeah yeah once he jumps
like
sprinting away from him and he'll try to
catch up
oh but nice job jacob you did it you
hate
to see it you really hate to see it i
thought it was
neat all right freeze him oh yeah sorry
i'm gonna try that
okay let's bring him on over again what
if i just go through here
do you guys want to do lava or forest uh
which way which way led to this i have
had a lot of trouble with lava so i'm
gonna have a
farm forest let's go forest let's do
forest
get the golden bug get the soul oh
nice
oh christ
oh no oh no well i uh so i died
i died what it's fine
hello ghost friend it's fine it was
right at the last second soon
we'll all be live soon okay
oh look a hamster let's have ourselves a
spit
oh no that hamster went really far
it's fine no hamster no
the hamster's running running for it oh
leprechaun
nice nice he's dead
oh my god okay the left ground is
rainbow oh
yeah is there gold on the other side i
don't know
oh that's interesting i think i saw that
last time we played but
also didn't find any scary boy
what is it we're just going okay yeah
pretty suspicious there's no cooldown on
his throw
oh boomerang sorry superior weapon
this is going really poor oh my god
you're a piece of [ __ ] dude
you're a piece of guy there's another
one right there
careful john you only got one heart what
do we do about these spiders
throw boomerangs at them no i don't have
one of those
oh no oh my god at least you can freeze
them now
that's handy jacob did you kill john
jacob
jacob what the [ __ ] i don't really have
no control over what's happening
who is this lady oh actually i think if
you kill that spider it will give you uh
sticky bombs oh i need an australian
feel like they're sticky bombs get the
goop oh curse
everybody's scary here you're cursed
oh monkeys look out for monkeys
yesterday
sacrifice him i'm trying bringing you
back buddy
sacrifice him alive oh yeah there we go
got him i got you snake
oh by the way pro tip alana i could have
told you this like four hours ago but
you always want to throw vases out i did
not know that
i was not aware of that throw them i
always been smacking them good to know
make
cause sometimes they have enemies inside
of him yeah i just tend to wait
hamsters here jacob i'm just chilling
i'm just chilling i'm staying away from
the door i'm chillin
teamwork team monkey work
yeah no i'm okay okay oh god no there's
two monkeys
oh my god oh what the [ __ ] monkey
sweater i mean the hamster oh i killed
myself with a boot prank
did you oh my god
don't worry guys we got this you're
supposed to teach me how to throw one
goddamn lord lord thank you for asking
matt
i actually made a hands command somebody
do exclamation point hands
yes i made it in a nightbot oh
he spawns the curse get him
i froze him i frizzed i froze them
out all right hold on yeah what up
i mean if it works
it works watch out it
i don't like these spikes yeah wow oh
just just an ankle brick oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] i thought i'd grab it oh my
god is goddamn donkey kong junior up in
this [ __ ]
[Music]
there's an exit wait there's one
the [ __ ] is this there's one lower
really
down below there's a monkey oh oh i got
a ghost face wait it's a trick it's a
trick don't do don't do ghost face set
ghost face down
okay you won't hit 3 000 oh my gosh
holy heck thank you everyone so i'm
fairly certain that if we were to pick
up that totem at the bottom
the thing that exploded would have
created a tunnel
okay jumping six dollars asteroids there
are only five
bikes we're here today
i think that's that's what we're called
up to thank you so much everyone that's
amazing
sorry i was reading the donations to
charity that people are making
yeah can i help it all here though
no no no you can help with his little
titties come out but we're not we're
gonna skip that part
hey you need help with titties he has
little titties he's got a little please
they're not really that little but oh
he's got he got big no
they are he got positions
i want my friends back wait here oh hey
oh hello hello oh this is nice
it's really nice uglier is this the
rhinoceros
inside jacob whoa look at you almost
killed me you son of a [ __ ]
spooky [ __ ] on the top right what's
up what's up good to see you oh how
scary they
what's up
[Music]
oh you gotta leak at your ceiling look
at that oh
don't worry about that yeah that's
what's up
um i'm scared of this level because i
don't recognize anything
yeah also it looks like nothing did i
actually take pictures will i find that
somewhere oh
this guy who's this cool guy that's our
new bud can we hire him dad
what shawn i'm going to gamble i'm
gambling
[Music]
oh that walrus is sexy that walrus has
cleavage oh
wait is can we win that one six seven
or seven yeah or no the seven is the
shotgun
yeah i think that's just the lady who
owns the gambling station oh my god i
love himself
yeah she is a a catch look at that hair
knows what is what's that look at that
thing he looks nice
you don't not want to jump on that
okay anyways let's go this way
[Applause]
oh my god
i'm so sorry i was just throwing the
dice and then i was so
beautiful i just hit the blonde guy with
the duck
here's the guy he's hanging there you go
oh my god i'm so sorry
whoa whoa pick up that key open up oh my
gosh
here first it's just like skyrim what
the [ __ ]
what was supposed to happen we did it
yeah we finished the game can't believe
we uh
well that's right i guess
well that was fun y'all oh my god it was
very fun
sexy walrus rips
you so much oh this is abused
good jacob i'll save you jacob or else
no no
wait hold on hold on alana stop whipping
real quick okay yeah sure
why are you gonna grab me [ __ ] off dude
ah [ __ ]
oh no it's all going south no
oh
[Laughter]
excellent
oh god did we just fight off a sexy
walrus is that what it happened at the
end of the stream we just that's that's
that's what broke us
yeah i think she's the sexy like
what are we supposed to do you know yeah
you see a character that's too
attractive yeah you want to fight some
dudes all sets
game's great well that was fun guys
very fun
[Music]
all time i have more work to do
excellent
have fun with that yeah well dude you
all have a wonderful friday wonderful
weekend
of course yeah come on my friends
goodbye
and to the people in the chat thanks for
joining
um if you're on youtube i have made it
members only to slowly transition
to when i eventually partner on twitch
which will happen at some point
um but most importantly thank you all
for three thousand dollars tonight
that's amazing
uh yeah hoping that we can hit 10 000 by
the end of february
seems unlikely it is a short month it is
a short month but we'll try
we'll try um and i will be doing a live
stream tomorrow
uh at twitch.tv brightspot live i will
be djing and also
you know it's it's basically like an
active live show really so
check that out if you're around 2 p.m
pacific time
and uh otherwise i'll see you guys next
stream which is
i think when i next have a stream
scheduled for
tuesday smoking dragons
and then i don't know i'll probably
stream some point next week on my own
channel i guess
i don't know we'll figure it out uh have
a good night everyone